One weakness of the encrypted key exchange is that passwords have to be stored.
One possible improvement would be to encrypt using a hash of the password
instead of the password itself.
In the first step, the client sends some identifying information
along with the first part of the key exchange, but this time it's encrypted with the hash of p.
Likewise, in the second step, the server response is encrypted
with the hash of p instead of p.
We want to know does this work?
The options are, yes, it provides further protection against a dictionary attack.
Yes, but it doesn't provide much advantage since now an attacker who learns
the hash of p doesn't need to learn p.
No, it prevents the client and server from establishing a shared key,
since the server can't invert the hash.
Or, no, it has a serious security vulnerability.